les ateliers nesting apparu en 2009 en
france se développe de plus en plus mais
en quoi consiste-t-il exactement afin de
protéger la santé d'un nouveau né on lui
créer un environnement intérieur sain et
pour découvrir ces techniques la maison
de quartier de la verrière a organisé un
atelier en partenariat avec la mutualité
française et l'association w e cf
on commence l'atelier en faisant un tour
des polluants de l'habitat pour que les
personnes puissent prendre conscience
que chacun au sein de son propre habitat
à ses propres paulo et ensuite on
travaille pour traitement avec des
produits sur table on prend ces produits
on regarde les étiquettes on regarde les
pictogrammes de danger on regarde les
labels on regarde la composition des
produits pour nous apprendre à
identifier les pôles ont qui sont cachés
dans ses produits de consommation
courante
apprendre à les identifier pour mieux
les éviter et mieux protéger sa santé
l'occasion pour les femmes de ce
quartier de s'informer sur les produits
les moins de visibilité à santés des
pratiques d'hygiène à modifier car elles
ont aussi découvert que la pollution
intérieure et la plupart du temps
invisible un tapis tout neuf il n'est
pas polluant
si il est polluant parce qu'il est neuf
il y a des denrées à l'intérieur et qui
font que des fibres qui sont polluantes
donc bien sûr on veut pas tout supprimer
mais savoir au moins que quand on
déballe par exemple un nouveau meuble il
y a de la pollution il ya les vernis à
tout ça qu'ils sont dans le meuble en
question si on peut le mettre un peu son
balcon quand le maître dans la maison
c'est mieux mobilier produits du
quotidien et bricolage présente des
risques où se révèle dangereux pour la
santé et les bébés sont les plus
vulnérables face aux effets des
polluants chimiques